the opening scene features a journalist
and artist re who visits an underground
construction site somewhere in Denmark
in order to document the life of workers
there she takes an elevator and makes
her way to the underground where the
construction of a Metro is going on
while guiding her deeper into the tunnel
one of the workers hands her with a
makeshift apparatus used for breathing
under claustrophobic situations he also
mentally prepares her in case something
goes wrong inside the tunnel moving
deeper re comes across a group of
workers with whom she shares some
pastries and coffee while having a brief
chitchat after this she begins wandering
around the site taking pictures of the
workers and asking them several
questions regarding their job and
families she discovers that the workers
are from all over the world all speaking
different languages and having different
backgrounds despite these differences
she finds a commonality that all of them
are away from their families and are
longing to see them this makes her feel
bad and she pies them for working in
such conditions sometime later re comes
across Evo the man in charge of the
project he is currently fixing a leakage
in the air pipe with his Apprentice
Baron she requests EVO to take her to
the main drill so that she can see how
things actually work the latter agrees
and leads her there but he does not
allow her to enter the cutter head
behind the main compartment citing its
risk of minimal oxygen level despite
this re convinces them by saying that
she is authorized to go anywhere she
wants while in the chamber she talks to
the men and also takes their picture as
their conversation unfolds Evo tells her
that the engineers do their job with
their computers and lasers but they
still rely on him to crawl into the
cutter head under pressure and change
the Cutters with bare hands not long
after a crew member named Adrien shows
up and argues with EVO for letting a
journalist into the main chamber he
informs re that there are only two
oxygen tanks to circulate enough air in
the chamber so he pulls her out of there
and locks their Chamber from the outside
before proceeding with an inspection
process however he does allow her to
watch the inspection process via camera
and through the window Adrien then pumps
the oxygen inside while Evo and baron
wait for enough pressure to be built
before entering the cutter head amidst
this Baron shows her a water bottle
getting squeezed which makes her realize
that the pressure level inside the
chamber is similar to being far under
the ocean as the pressure increases to
its limit Evo enters the cutter head and
Begins the inspection he learns that the
cutter number three is not working so he
uses a walkie-talkie to ask Adrien to
arrange a new one the lad reminds him it
is only an inspection day and that it is
not necessary to address the issue
immediately however Evo insists on
fixing the cutter because one way or
another it has to be fixed their
conversation is abruptly interrupted
when Adrien hears an alarm for carbon
monoxide poisonous gas somewhere in the
tunnel before he can comprehend the
situation he notices smoke filling the
tunnel indicating a fire he quickly
instructs re to rush to the refugee
chamber where she will be safe however
she panics and she does not know the way
and she is not familiar enough to
navigate it on her own afraid that she
might get lost Adrien locks her into a
medical chamber which is connected to
the chamber Evo and baron are in he then
turns on the oxygen and leaves shortly
after the chamber's lights suddenly go
out for a while when they come back on
she tries to look outside from a tiny
window but all she sees is pitch black
darkness in a state of panic R Taps on
another window and manages to catch Evo
and Baron's attention they ask how she
ended up there and she explains that
Adrien put her in there to keep her safe
but now he is nowhere to be seen the
guys then ask her to remain calm
assuring her that help is on the way
time passes by and the chamber's
temperature keeps on Rising probably due
to the fire outside this causes R to
sweat heavily so she removes some layers
of her clothing however the situation
only gets tougher as the temperature
surpasses 50° unable to tolerate it she
knocks on the window and expresses her
uneasiness Evo then tells her to open
the chambers's door and come to their
compartment R tries doing so but learns
that the door has been jammed she then
looks around and spots a wooden log
which she uses to hit the wheel knob
this ultimately opens the door once the
opening space is enough they pull her
out of the chamber and let her into
theirs ree finally experiences a sense
of relief and chugs down down an entire
bottle of water quenching her extreme
thirst but since she's removed those
layers The Thirst of the others is far
from quenched after taking a moment to
regain composure she asks if they're
going to die Baron also appears to be
scared which makes the situation even
more intense however Evo asks both of
them to stay calm so that they consume
less oxygen re questions why they are
waiting here instead of doing something
to make their way out in response Evo
explains that the pressure outside the
chamber is is so high that opening the
door could lead to an explosion and
might deplete all of their oxygen he
also adds that there is a medical supply
area outside but it is too dangerous for
any of them to go there at least until
the third act moreover they are not even
sure that the supplies are still there
as a result the best thing they can do
is wait after a while ree's phone rings
and the men get excited thinking that
her phone has signal however it is
actually an alarm to remind her to pick
up her daughter from school the three
then begin to talk about their families
and re shows them some photos and videos
of her young daughter later while
everyone is sleeping she comes up with
an idea and tries sneaking back into the
medical chamber in the process Evo wakes
up so she makes up a lie saying she is
just going to urinate he then helps get
into the chamber and even closes the
door for her privacy in an unexpected
turn of events R tries to lock the door
by putting back the wheel knob it turns
out that she was planning to lock Evo
and B on inside the main compartment and
stay in the medical Bay with her hidden
supplies however her plan is thwarted as
Evo quickly realizes what she's doing
and opens the door hastily the two guys
then make their way into the medical
chamber and find a breathing apparatus
which she had been hiding for this
entire time enraged by her betrayal Evo
starts to fight for the Breather when
the lights suddenly go off again by the
time it restores Evo has the Breather in
his hand and he orders Baron to tie her
up now that that he is armed with the
breathing apparatus Evo decides to go
out to the refugee chamber and get some
supplies for all of them during this the
three of them have a short debate on who
should go out as they no longer trust
each other Baron claims that he needs to
survive for his family because he owes
them a lot of money despite this Evo
somehow manages to convince them
assuring that he will return for their
rescue as he prepares to open the
chamber a rescue team shows up outside
bringing great relief to the occupants
the team instructs them to decompress
the chamber so that they can open the
door from outside heeding to their
instruction Evo releases the gas
pressure to make the chamber gas free
while they wait R inquires why Baron
owes money to his family to which he
reveals that he was kidnapped a few
years ago which forced his family to
borrow a huge sum of money his sad story
touches her heart so she promises to
help him as soon as they make their way
out in the midst of the decompressing
process a massive explosion occurs
outside the chamber claiming the lives
of all the rescuers as a consequence the
temperature inside the chamber suddenly
Rises and the things around them start
to melt this prompts the three occupants
to rush back to the main compartment
when decompression starts taking its
toll they are forced to retreat further
into the restricted cutter head a small
opening above the main compartment Baron
crawls out and helps re but Evo passes
inside the compartment the two somehow
managed to drag him out but accidentally
drop him from a height resulting in his
serious injuries they then hurriedly
climb down and try to wake Evo but he
eventually passes away while Baron
Mourns his death rehears some sound and
realizes that they are close to trains
filled with a new sense of hope she
first shuts the door behind them to
prevent any more heat and smoke from
entering the cutterhead and then begins
digging her way around the walls she
soon finds a hole so she hurridly asks
Baron to let go of his friend's body and
accompany her Baron then crawls through
the muddy hole while re retrieves her
breathing apparatus from Evo before
following him upon reaching the other
side Baron turns around to pull re in as
they make their way forward the two
inadvertently fall into a pit and get
engulfed by Darkness R quickly takes out
her phone and turns on the flashlight
only to find Baron unconscious in a
state of panic she takes the breathing
apparatus and begins digging in random
directions she hopes to find an exit but
even after a lot of hard work nothing
appears distraught re then wakes Baron
up and tells him that they need to hug
each other to stay warm Baron has no
problem with this at all after some time
they begin to struggle for breath due to
very low oxygen levels R and baron share
the breathing apparatus hoping they can
survive until rescue arrives but each
time they pass it their struggle
intensifies which eventually leads to a
desperate fight for the Breather in the
end Baron manages to keep the apparatus
and re passes out but he doesn't get to
use it for long as he too Falls
unconscious a short while later a light
penetrates the darkness and they are
found by the rescue team the scene then
Cuts forward to Baron who wakes up on a
medical plane with an oxygen mask on his
face he looks around and finds re on the
other side lying down and breathing with
a tube in her mouth he initially
believes that she is dead but his
assumption turns out to be wrong as she
soon regains her Consciousness the movie
ends as the two of them stti at each
other and the camera pans out subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching